welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man in this video
we're breaking down the deleted scenes
for spider-man no way home several have
hit the web in the lead up to the
digital release and we now have a lot of
details on what was originally supposed
to be in the movie throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it all down
but if you want to stick around for
videos on your favorite spider menace
then make sure you hit the thumbs up
button and also subscribe to the channel
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's dive into the spoiler
verse with these deleted scenes
okay so the first major one that we know
about featured matt murdock and foggy
now sorry happy hogan in the film we get
a brief scene in which matt tells peter
that the charges won't stick but he then
says happy is gonna have to lie her up
because the feds are still coming for
him john favreau of course played foggy
nelson in the daredevil movie opposite
ben affleck and the deleted scene was
going to take more of a focus on him and
matt murdock titled happy's very good
lawyer the scene focused on the pair
discussing his apparent illegal
acquisition of stock tech and how it
helped to fund peter's terrorist attacks
yes he did it the murderer got away with
it hashtag mysterio was right mysterio
was right stop this we don't know that's
all though we don't have the full ins
and outs of this scene it is theorized
that there's someone opposite the pair
and that this could be foggy himself
played once more by eldon henson
daredevil itself has now just moved over
to disney plus and with kingpin showing
up in hawkeye it does make sense that he
would pop up too though we're gonna have
to wait until the full scene's released
to know for sure it's also been
confirmed that morgan stark would have
made an appearance during the scene
which goes over the stolen stock tech
lexi rabe was supposed to return as the
character and we would have got flashes
of her during the montage in these
moments in addition to this we were also
going to get more focus on the
interrogation scene with damage control
which would flesh out peter's
interaction with them it would also
showcase him seeking legal help and some
of the questioning that was put towards
ned mj and or some a personally i think
the way that they do it in the movie
with matt keynes coming down works a lot
better and it's way more impactful to
introduce him in a scene with a hard cut
and somewhat of a mic drop matt murdock
being officially brought into the mcu
was a major aspect of the movie that got
a lot of marvel maniacs hyped up early
on and i think the way that they do it
is much better than anything else we
could have got now we do have a big list
of deleted scenes and it seems like the
majority of these centered around things
early on in the movie this includes an
undercroft montage graduation day an
extended doctor strange entrance and a
couple more daily bugle reports also i
forgot to mention in our every easter
egg video that when peter enters midtown
high it's meant to parallel his entrance
to the school in homecoming the movie
had him basically being a complete
unknown as he walks through the crowd
whereas no way home has everyone staring
at him they all stand there filming the
character on their phones and then head
over to youtube to like comment and
subscribe the best channel out there see
you chump
now these reports basically had people
ringing in and talking to j jonah
jameson about how spider-man saved the
day at several points in the movie one
was in the aftermath of the fight with
electro that basically talked about how
he stayed there all night helping to fix
the power lines mr burke you're saying
you saw spider-man with your own eyes
destroying multiple power lines well
technically he did destroy those power
lines
well there you have it folks firsthand
from an unimpeachable witness wait i i
wasn't finished i'm sorry spider-man was
stopping this guy who was absorbing all
the energy from the lines
spider-man stopped that dude and then he
spent the whole night repairing the
damage i saw it all it was amazing
we'll have to uh circle back and confirm
this folks
we'll be right back after a brief word
from daily bugle supplements
the only other daily fix you need and
we're out okay which one of you former
employees vetted that nut job there's
also a bit on the flash's book
flashpoint available in all good
bookshops now he and i have been best
friends for years i mean this is this is
a school that we went together for years
now i mean he's constantly following me
up those steps and you know we get into
trouble we do what we can you know
as if our public schools weren't
dangerous enough between the lead paint
asbestos and salisbury steak made from
military horses
don't believe me check out my four-part
expose on dailybugle.net
and the villains were a major part of
the movie and in the film tom holland
had a bit of a funny scene where he gave
me the rundown on them there's a
electric man a sound man there's a
dinosaur man there's an octopus man
and then there's this old man mm-hmm
i knew that again
i love the constant use of man here with
some stupid name in front of it and it
does kind of add to the comedy of the
movie beyond this we also got a couple
of seconds released in which the
villains peter and may all stand in an
elevator together as they head to
happy's apartment it's a pretty fun
moment of the full cast on screen
together at the same time that i quite
like because it's nice just seeing them
having this monday moment before it all
kicks off the power cuts for me later on
so she can't go to the elevator doc ock
salmon and electro go out the window and
peter and goblin crash through several
floors on their way out this moment in
the elevator was meant to juxtapose that
and show them going up in a really
sensible normal way before all hell
breaks loose now apparently this was cut
because the director wanted to keep up
the pace of the film and have us go from
the sanctorum directly to the apartment
we just had the muradi mention chase so
john watts wanted to keep everything at
a high level but i would have actually
liked to have seen this play out it's
very much to come before the storm i
think it would have worked well to
balance the drama going on and just give
us a quick breather now speaking of
breathers time for a joke what's
spider-man's favorite day fly day
what's spider-man's favorite month
web you are
what's the opposite of happy hogan sad
hogan because aunt may is dead anyway
speaking of february we now have our
competition winners for the last month
on screen right now so if that's you
then get in touch with me at twitter at
heavy spoilers also giving away three
copies of spider-man no way home but
i'll tell you how you can get your hands
on them at the end of the video now we
also know from the concept art and
interviews with the creative team that
mysterio was supposed to return in the
movie come the end of the film we watch
as the multiverse is cracked open and
several characters come across that now
peter parker is spider-man during the
shot in which we get craven the hunter
and scorpion you can also catch the
distinctive fishbowl head of the master
of illusions and the creative team
confirmed it was indeed supposed to be
him mysterio of course exposed peter's
identity to the world and thus it does
make sense that he was going to be the
villain that showed up concept art for
the movie has since been released and it
shows mysterio was supposed to duke it
out with doctor strange at the statue of
liberty if we look at his powers or
rather illusions and far from home they
were actually based around strange's
magic and it would have been great to
see them face off against each other
even though mysterio is faker than iggy
azalea's accent
yeah may scraping the barrel of jokes
from 2017 there moving on the creative
team actually discussed this in more
detail and they went over how his
appearance would have worked speaking at
ign fan fest 2022 they said how opening
up the multiverse at the end meant
opening up infinite possibilities on who
could come through they really wanted
mysterio back but they realized that if
they brought in one character they'd
have to bring him more he couldn't just
have one from the multiverse
breakthrough at the end so they'd need
to at least have a handful for it not to
feel disappointing but then it would
feel slightly overwhelming he'd end up
distracting from the main battle that
was going on and in the end they just
kept it simple with a focus on the five
villains we also know from the concept
are that america chavez was supposed to
appear and that she was going to be the
one that brought toby and andrew across
we have a scene at the dudgeons where
she's standing in the middle with
several characters around her and
america can also be seen at the statue
of liberty battle i've already done a
full video on this so i don't want to go
over old ground but she had quite a
substantial role in the film in case you
don't know america has the power to open
portals across the multiverse but due to
the release order of the films being
flipped this didn't happen instead we
got ned discovering he's a wizard and
bringing them across in a charming very
charming little scene in the kitchen
which i do quite like now if you catch
your mind back to the build-up of the
movie then you might remember that tom
holland's brother harry was supposed to
be in a scene but this too got cut and
if he was a thief that robbed the store
and then peter caught him and strung him
up it was at this point that the green
paint was thrown over peter and he ended
up having to turn his suit inside out
for the fight with electro now we also
know that toby maguire was supposed to
fight with the green goblin on his
glider the pair would stand on it
together and duke it out in a battle
that was somewhat reminiscent of the
playstation 2 game one of the big
disappointments about no way home was
that toby and goblin didn't really
interact all that much and though they
could in a future film with him ending
up alive i did want to see them at least
have a toe-to-toe at some point the
deleted scene hurts more than finding
out that you only got one thousand
dollars even though the ad said three
thousand
spider-man fought sandman and the
amazing spider-man for the lizard but
the face-off with the foe was sadly
missing their rivalry was one of the
most memorable things about the original
spider-man film and i kind of hope that
we at least get them on screen together
again at some point and lastly is the my
favorite part here no bloopers
hey
what's going on guys it's
jacob and zade here
we're about to show you the bloopers
sometimes movie making seems very
serious but a lot of times
comedy gold happens uh well there's a
lot of falling and swearing i hope that
they'll bleep that out [ __ ]
god
i think it's time to go roll it
nice
anyway that's all the deleted scenes
info that we have released over the last
couple of days and i hope you enjoyed
the video obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on whether you think
things should have been cut or not so
comment below and let me know we are in
a competition right now and giving away
three copies of spider-man nowaday home
on the 15th of march and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the scenes
you picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen are now so that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out
breakdown of all the easter eggs in
spider-man no way home which will be
linked on screen right now we've got
some great cameos from other youtubers
in it so definitely go check it out
right after this without the way thanks
for sticking through the video i've been
paul i'll see in the next one take care
peace